[Applaudissements]
dans la nuit du 28 septembre 2009 j'ai
coupé internet pas dans ma maison
pardon mon quartier pas dans ma ville
même nom
j'ai coupé internet pour toute la
roumanie pour nos six millions de
clients
six millions de personnes sans connexion
internet
plus rien ni nique vous imaginez-vous
sans connexion réseau
je travaille chez un opérateur
international avec des ingénieurs archi
compétents dont le métier est de garder
ce réseau en marche 24 heures sur 24
quoi qu'il arrive bon oeil coupures
d'électricité cyberattaques catastrophes
naturelles même donc je ne coupe jamais
bon réseau je prends soin jeu le
bichonne je le répare mais je ne le
coupent jamais et pourtant ce soir là
cela faisait des heures que le réseau
buggé et tout ce que nous avions essayé
ne faisait qu'empirer la situation
j'ai alors pris une décision qui allait
à l'encontre de tout ce que j'avais
appris et de tout ce à quoi j'avais
travaillé jusqu alors je ne voyais plus
qu'une seule solution pour que tout
redémarre
j'ai tout état même pas peur
ce qui est intéressant ici c'est le
processus mental qui m'a permis de
prendre cette décision
ce processus est important pour vous
dans un monde qui change de façon
exponentielle où chaque innovation vient
nourrir la prochaine vague d'innovations
il devient parfois difficile de prendre
des décisions pour illustrer sa il a
fallu 38 ans pour que la télévision
rassemble 50 millions de téléspectateurs
fortnight annie moins de six mois pour
réunir 50 millions de joueurs 80 fois
plus vite donc prendre la décision
devient complexe en ville je parle pas
ici de petites décisions comme qu'elle
tee shirt je vais mettre demain matin
encore que non je parle de vraies
décisions comme quel métier je veux
faire dans cinq ans quelles études je
veux suivre les décisions parfois lourde
de sens et pour lesquels nous n'avons
pas forcément tous les éléments pour
faire des choix rationnels et donc la
question devient alors est-ce que je
vais prendre la bonne décision
je suis désolé je n'ai pas de réponse
universelle à cette question et personne
n'en a en fait la seule vraiment
mauvaise décision serait de ne pas en
prendre
dans un monde qui change vite plus ça va
vite plus se laisser porter au fil de
l'eau ne mène à rien mais quand le monde
change vite ce qui marchait avant ça
marche souvent plus pas facile de mener
votre bateau comme vos parents l'ont
fait avant vous ils ont navigué sur un
océan qui n'existe plus et qui ne
ressemble pas à celui sur lequel vous
vous devrez naviguer et en plus nous les
français nous sommes champions du nord
de la théorie en france on adore la
théorie nous français préférons regarder
une carte de navigation plutôt que lever
la tête et surveiller la mer parfois
même quand le monde a changé que notre
vieille carte ne vaut plus rien donc
vous devrez prendre votre bateau
explorez votre mère et découvrir ce
nouveau monde qui s'offre choisissez le
cap naviguer à l'air facile
est ce que ce sera si facile que ça se
voyait non évidemment nous ne sommes pas
parfaits
nous faisons tous des obtient lever la
main ce qui dans la salle n'ont jamais
fait d'erreur
voilà
donc nous faisons tous des erreurs c'est
inévitable même pas crédible
c'était évitable je fais des erreurs
vos parents vos profs font aussi vous
faites des erreurs et vous en retrait et
c'est normal ce n'est jamais agréable de
prendre des mauvaises décisions et je
peux vous dire que des mauvaises
décisions dans ma vie je tends des
prises tiens une notamment dont j'ai
encore on aujourd'hui
quand j'étais tout jeune manager voyant
mon équipe ne travaillez pas comme je le
voulais j'ai fait le jeune coq
je me suis moqué d'eux et j'ai pris une
décision qui était vraiment nul
je leur ai confisqué leurs laptops tant
qu'ils ne travaillaient pas comme il le
fallait
la honte ça a été terrible
ils se sont sentis traités comme des
gamins alors qu'ils étaient tous plus
expérimenté et plus âgés que moi
évidemment c'est est totalement
inefficace
j'ai perdu la confiance de mon équipe
une véritable catastrophe
on croit trop souvent que ceux qui
réussissent sont ceux qui ne font jamais
d'erreur quand l'air de tout savoir qu
une grande gueule
pensez à quelqu'un
eh bien non c'est faux pour mener son
bateau à bon port
je vois trois capacités essentielles
dans la vie première capacité décidées
dans un monde qui change peu dire quoi
décider dans un monde qui change
ça veut dire prendre des décisions même
quand on n'a pas tous les éléments pour
cela est accepté de revoir et de changer
ses décisions quand le contexte change
dans un monde qui change vite
encore une fois ce qui marchait avant ce
qui était une bonne décision et à trois
mois peut se révéler désastreux dans
deux semaines déployer tout grand les
voiles par grand beau temps et grand
soleil c'est bien réduire fortement la
voilure
dès que le vent se lève trop fort et les
vagues se creuse c'est bien aussi si
vous avez engagé des études dans une
filière et qu'au bout de six mois
vous vous rendez compte que ce n'est pas
ce que vous aimez
n'attendez pas quatre ans d'être dans
une impasse pour vous réorienter ne vous
mentez pas changer de cap
deuxième capacité apprendre de ses
erreurs
c'est dur pour son ego de reconnaître
ses erreurs je peux vous dire que c'est
encore plus dur de refaire la même
erreur
encore et encore et donc il faut
détecter et accepter que l'erreur vient
de nom et pas du monde autour de lui et
ça c'est très dur mais c'est seulement
ensuite qu'on peut écouter les autres
confrontés ces décisions à la réalité
la mer est pas la carte et c'est ainsi
qu'on apprend de ses erreurs et qu'on
grandit
quand j'étais tout jeune manager j'ai
pris une décision objectivement vraiment
nul si j'avais pas pris du recul et
accepter que le problème c'était mon
l'attitude est pas la leur jamais je
n'aurais pu évoluer en tant que manager
et alors on m'aurait dit gentiment ou
pas d'aller voir ailleurs
j'ai perdu temporairement gouvernail
mais je crache pas aussi bien pu
basculer par dessus bord troisième
capacité à travailler en équipe
quand on vit dans un bateau on n'est
jamais seul
il ya tout un équipage d'ailleurs même
ceux qui partent en solitaire s'appuie
sur une très solide équipe derrière bien
dans le monde professionnel c'est par m
il n'y a de réussite que collective oui
j'ai pris moi la décision de couper
internet
en cette nuit fatale du 28 septembre
mais c'est parce que je pouvais
m'appuyer sur une équipe en qui j'avais
toute confiance et qui avait toutes les
compétences pour mettre cette décision
en oeuvre une confiance réciproque qui
leur a permis eux de comprendre et
d'accepter cette décision pour le moins
étonnante et de la mettre en oeuvre
efficacement et à la fin c'était notre
bonne décision
j'entends aussi dire que pour décider il
faut la confiance en soi c'est vrai
prendre des décisions demande de la
confiance en soi
bonne nouvelle chaque décision que vous
prendrez vous entraîne à en prendre
d'autres c'est comme le sport ça se
pratique c'est ainsi que petit à petit
vous construirez votre plus grand atout
dans la vie une confiance en vous solide
aux décisions seront plus rapide plus
fluide et vous prendrez du plaisir
il a continuellement apprendre de vos
erreurs et emmenez votre bateau toujours
plus loin sur cet océan changeant qu'est
la vie pour conclure
prenez des décisions
confrontez vous à la réalité et apprenez
toujours de vos erreurs adaptez-vous
continuellement aux changements comme
c'est difficile
beaucoup vont lentement prudemment et
ils ne prennent aucun risque avec leur
bateau vous vous pouvez faire rapidement
la d6 la différence par vos décisions
barret votre bateau un peu plus vite
calculé et assumer un peu plus de
risques et emmenez votre bateau toujours
plus loin dans des zones où il n'ya pas
de carte dans des zones où vous devrez
découvrir cette nouvelle mère et vous
devrez tracer la nouvelle carte par vos
décisions
prenez la barre de votre vie en
acceptant un monde changeant un certain
parfois difficile et qui peut même faire
peur mais aussi l'inde extraordinaire
opportunité si vous allez les chercher
et si la situation l'exigé coupez votre
réseau même pas peur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]